[Music]
welcome back so today we're working
through the eigenfaces example of how to
use the singular value decomposition to
decompose a very high dimensional data
set composed of human faces into a lower
dimensional representation in terms of
eigen faces so in the last video I
showed you how to load this Yale faces
database these images so we have 36
people and a bunch of images 64 images
for each of those people under different
lighting conditions and now what we're
gonna do is we're going to take this
massive data matrix and we're going to
compute the singular value decomposition
of it
so remember every single column of X
every single column vector of X is a
human face that has been reshaped into a
32,000 dimensional column vector and
what's neat about the SVD is that the
columns of you have exactly the same
size as the columns of X and so if I
reshape u 1 u 1 is a tall 32,000
dimensional column vector I can reshape
it into something that has the shape of
a face and this is what we're gonna call
our eigen faces ok are going to be the
columns of U so that's what we're gonna
do right now this is actually very very
simple we loaded the data from all faces
mat so we're gonna load this data we're
going to load in all of our training
faces there are actually 38 individuals
we're only going to use the first 36 to
build this model because we want to see
how it works on the other two that we
didn't train on and again we're gonna
compute the average face we're gonna
take the average of all of the columns
of X the average face and subtract it
out and then we're gonna compute the SVD
so here's where we subtracted out the
average face and we had to multiply it
by a vector of ones to subtract it from
every column and then we compute this
economy-sized SVD of X remember we want
the economy-sized SVD because I don't
want a 32,000 by 32,000 u matrix I only
want the first the first 24 2410 columns
corresponding to the nonzero singular
values ok so we're going to compute this
SVD
and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to plot the average face for you
and then I'm going to build a big matrix
of my eigen faces and we're gonna see
the first 64 eigenfaces plotted from
this SPD okay pretty simple but all of
the work is going in in this line 11
here where we actually compete the SVD
so loading the data computing the
average face and subtracting it off
that's all pretty easy and the SVD all
of the eigen decomposition is happening
in line 11 so let's run this and see
what we get it takes a little while to
load all the data and compute the SVD
just a couple seconds good it's
evaluating the currents the current code
I mean this is a pretty big matrix
32,000 by by 2,400 and I'm gonna make
this much much much bigger so you can
actually see all of these eigen faces
okay so these are the first 64
eigenfaces what I've done is I've taken
this first 64 columns of my u matrix
each of those columns I've reshaped into
an image a to an array that looks like
the shape of a face so this 30 mm vector
gets reshaped into an image and then
what I've done is I've plotted those
images along the rows of this big big
matrix okay it's just a cool way to plot
it and so what you see here are your 1st
2nd 3rd 4th eigenfaces all the way down
to your 64th eigen face down there and
there's more there are as many
eigenfaces as there are columns of data
so there's 2410 of these eigen faces I'm
just plotting the first the first few
and you can see actually there's some
really interesting structures that that
pop out immediately so the first couple
of eigen faces are like these kind of
creepy ghosty average blobs it's just
the things everybody has in common right
and everybody has eyes nose and a mouth
we're kind of all ovals with ovals and
you know ovals and stuff like that and
then what you start to see is the higher
the higher singular vectors or
eigenfaces these are left singular
vectors
start to capture different information
like shadows right this one has a shadow
on one side of the face
this one is capturing really bright
eyebrows or really dark eyebrows rather
and you can see this one looks like it
has a black eye and each of these
eigenfaces is starting to capture kind
of different features both of the
lighting and the structure of all of
those different human faces right all
those people look different and so what
we're capturing here is you know okay
maybe one person's eyes had deeper
eyebrows or less eyebrows or maybe one
person had longer nose or less long nose
and in addition it's capturing the
shadow information so this is a
decomposition of the data into these
eigen faces and then every single person
every column vector in X is just a
linear combination in these eigen faces
and what I'm going to show you soon is
that even if we threw away a bunch of
the eigen faces even if we only kept the
first few hundred rather than the first
2,400 we can do a pretty good job of
approximating our individual people's
faces just from a linear combination of
a few of these eigen faces and that
linear combination information is in
this Sigma V transpose so Sigma V
transpose each each column of that is
going to be the mixture of my eigenfaces
to give me person 1 person 2 and so on
and so forth ok very cool let's see it
looks like my average face didn't get
didn't get plotted so I'm just gonna
plot it here and this is what our
average face looks like so our average
face is kind of this weird you know
again
ghosty looking average face that looks
may be a little childish but it's a very
nondescript eigen face right this is the
composite average of every single image
in that database
notice that the shadows have been kind
of eliminated because they've averaged
out and this is what's what's remaining
ok and I think what we probably should
do remember every time you plot you
compute an SVD you should plot the
singular values on a log scale so I
think I think we should do that right
now so we're just gonna do semi log Y
of the diag of s and I'm gonna plot that
just here okay so these are the singular
vector suits our singular values of my
data matrix so this is the number of
modes I would keep are the rank of the
truncation from and of course there are
twenty four hundred and ten because
that's how many columns of X there are
so this goes up to 24 hundred and ten
and this is the magnitude of the log of
the singular value in the diagonal Sigma
notice this interesting behavior where
it slow slow slow slow slow and then it
drops off to machine precision ten to
the minus sixteen that's basically
because if you kept absolutely every
single one of these eigen faces you
would get an machine precision
approximation of this data matrix X you
essentially have zero error or as close
as a computer can represent you know ten
to the minus sixteen error if you had
every single singular value and singular
vector but what this is telling you is
that it doesn't drop off faster than
that you actually eventually would need
all of those features to get exact
representation of this data matrix X
okay but in principle you should be able
to zoom in on this a bit and see what
the structure is so this is the
structure if you zoom in a little bit
and what you see is kind of what we
always want to see in a singular value
distribution is that the first few
singular values carry most of the energy
this is most of the variance in the
faces and then it tapers off and there's
less and less and less and less
information now what I will show in the
next segment is that actually you do
need a fair number of singular values
maybe 400 or 800 before you actually
start capturing you know the really
subtle features that make one person
different than another person and we'll
walk through that in the next lecture so
what we'll do is we'll use these eigen
faces to reconstruct a new face that was
not in our original training library to
begin with okay thank you